in this video you're going to learn how
to solve rational equations we're going
to go through three examples together
see if you can do some of these on your
own and I want to show you an easy
method that I found works for most
students to solve these real quickly and
easily what I like to do first is get a
common denominator for all three of
these fractions so in order to do that
the first thing you want to do is Factor
the denominators as much as you can so
this one you can see is a difference of
two squares so it's going to factor as X
Plus 1 x minus 1. if you need to review
factoring check out some of my learn how
to factor videos but when I look at all
three of these fractions I can see that
this fraction has a denominator of X
Plus 1 x minus 1. this one only has an X
plus one it really needs an x minus one
so whatever I do to the denominator I
also have to do to the numerator because
that's like multiplying by 1 which
doesn't change the fraction just changes
the way that it looks and this one over
here x minus 1 we really need another X
plus one If I multiply the denominator
by X plus one I want to do that to the
numerator as well now you can see that
we have a common denominator for all
three of these these fractions and what
we're going to do now is we're going to
clear the denominators meaning we're
going to multiply this whole equation
both the left side and the right side by
this common denominator which is x minus
X plus 1. you can think of this as being
over one now if you were to distribute
this to this fraction here you can see
that x minus 1 X Plus 1 would cancel out
this denominator if you distribute it to
this fraction here you can see it's
going to cancel out this denominator and
if you distribute it to this fraction
here
cancels out this denominator so what
happens is you're clearing the
denominators by multiplying through that
equation by that common denominator
you're keeping the equation balanced
because you're doing it to both the left
and the right sides and so then now what
this does it makes it a lot easier to
solve because we're just left with the
numerator here which is 2x Plus
3x minus 3
equals
4X Plus 4.
okay so now let's just go ahead and
solve it's just like a normal kind of
easy algebra equation right
and so what we're going to do is we're
going to subtract 4X from both sides
add 3 to both sides
and now you can see this is coming out
to 1x is equal to 7 and what you want to
do before you
call it a day on that problem is you
want to take that seven and you want to
go back and look at the denominators and
see if it makes any of the denominators
equal to zero if it does that's called
an extraneous solution it's a false
answer and you would then say that
there's no solution but in this case we
just don't want the denominator the x
value to come out to negative 1 or
positive 1 because that would make the
factors in the denominator equal to zero
and you can't divide by zero that's
undefined in this case seven that's not
going to make the denominator zero so
this is a good answer let's take a look
at another example see if you can do
number two on your own if I was going to
do this what I would do is I'd Factor
the denominators as much as I can first
this is a difference of two squares X
plus two times x minus 2
this one you can think of as a fraction
by putting it over one because anything
divided by 1 is itself so now when we
look at all these denominators we want
to get a common denominator right so it
looks like we've got an X plus 2 x minus
2 we only have an X plus 2 here so that
means we need
an x minus 2. so I'll multiply that to
the numerator and denominator here we're
missing both an X plus 2 and an x minus
2. so we're going to have to multiply
those both to the numerator and
denominator now we can see that we have
a common denominator for all three
fractions so what we're going to do is
we're going to multiply the left side
and the right side by that common
denominator X plus 2 x minus 2. and
you're keeping it balanced because
you're doing it to both sides I just
like to think about it as multiplying
the entire equation by that and again
you can think of this as being over one
so what happens when you multiply it to
this fraction here the X plus 2 and x
minus 2 in the numerator cancel with the
X plus two x minus 2 in the denominator
same thing here same thing here so what
ends up happening is we end up clearing
the denominators and that's a nice
feeling right just crossing out all
those fractions we just have to deal
with the numerators now right so let's
go ahead and do that so we're just going
to simplify we've got 4X minus 8
okay and then here if we multiply these
together remember X plus 2 times x minus
2 that was this x squared minus 4. so
I'm going to write this as x squared
minus 4 and this minus 2 I'm going to
think of as a negative 2 that I'm
Distributing into the parentheses there
so that's going to give us negative 2x
squared plus 8.
equals x okay now we have a little bit
simpler equation to work with right
so what I'm going to do is I'm going to
get everything on one side of the
equation and set it equal to zero so if
I do that let's see I've got let me add
the negative 2x squared to the right so
that'll give us positive 2x squared let
me subtract the 4X so 1X minus 4X is
going to give us negative 3x
and then here we have negative eight
plus eight which is actually zero those
guys cancel so now we've got everything
on one side we set it equal to zero and
we're going to factor so the only thing
we can really factor out here is a
greatest common factor of X which leaves
us with two x minus three when you have
it in factored form like this you can
set each group equal to zero each factor
equal to zero so x equals zero and two x
minus three equals zero add three to
both sides
and divide by two
so you can see that X is coming out to
three halves or zero now what you want
to do like just like the previous
problem is you want to go back and you
want to say hmm does that make my
denominator equal to zero well the only
thing that would make the denominator is
zero is if x was negative two or
positive two that's not what we have
here so these are both solutions to this
equation so great job let's take a look
at one more example okay if you're still
with me here I just wanted to mention
that I've got a two video courses for
sale in algebra one and an Algebra 2
video course for sale so if you like the
way that I explain things check out
those video courses in the description
below and let's do this last example see
if you can do it on your own see if you
can test yourself here this one's a
challenging one if I was going to do it
the first thing remember is to factor
the denominators as much as you can so
in this first one you can see what
multiplies to positive 15 but adds to
negative 8 that's negative 5 and
negative 3.
over here it looks like this denominator
is already factored and then this one
looks like we have a difference of two
squares so that's going to factor to X
plus 3 times x minus 3. okay so now we
have to get a common denominator for all
three fractions right so it looks like
we have an x minus 5 here and x minus 5
here we don't have an x minus 5 here so
let's go ahead and multiply the
numerator and denominator by
x minus 5.
over here we have an x minus 3. here we
have an x minus three this one doesn't
have an x minus three so let's multiply
the numerator and denominator here by x
minus 3.
and let's see what else we're missing an
X plus three we have an X plus 3 here we
don't have an X plus 3 here
so let's multiply the numerator and
denominator by that
this one also doesn't have an X plus 3
so let's multiply the numerator
and denominator by X Plus 3. now when we
look it looks like now we have a common
denominator for all three fractions so
what we're going to do is we're going to
clear those denominators by multiplying
through by our common denominator which
is the X plus 3 x minus 3.
and x minus 5 and if we do that remember
this is over 1 and distribute to
everything left and right side to keep
that equation balanced what that does is
it clears
the denominators and we've got a much
easier equation to solve we just have
these numerators so let's go ahead and
simplify the numerators here what's left
we're going to do the distributive
property twice or foil if you know that
method this is going to come out to x
squared
plus 3x plus 1X Plus 3. over here x
minus 3 times X plus 3 comes out to x
squared minus 9.
but you see this minus 1 this is like a
negative 1 that I'm going to distribute
so that's going to come out to negative
x squared plus nine
and then that's equal to
x squared minus 5X
okay so now we've cleared the
denominators we just have what's left
here from the numerators we just have to
solve this equation so let's see what we
have here we have negative x squared and
positive x squared those cancel we have
3x plus 1X is 4X
3 plus 9 is 12.
and x squared minus 5x on the right side
so because I've got an x squared term
and an x to the first term what I'm
going to do is get everything on one
side of the equation and set it equal to
zero so let's go ahead and subtract the
4X and the 12 from both sides
to keep it balanced this is going to
cancel we're just going to be left with
0 equals x squared minus 9x minus 12.
okay now that's interesting because what
multiplies to negative 12 but adds to
negative 9 well there really isn't
anything so what we're going to have to
do here is we're going to have to do the
quadratic formula or the completing the
square or you could graph it any
different methods to solve quadratic
equations I'll just do a quadratic
formula so we've got negative B which
would be the opposite of B so that'd be
positive 9.
plus or minus the square root of B
squared
so that's going to be negative 9 squared
minus 4 times a which is 1.
times C which is negative 12.
all divided by
2 times a which is 1.
okay so you know your quadratic formula
so this is going to come out to let's
see 9 plus or minus the square root of
Plus 48.
all divided by 2
and simplify this down a little bit more
this comes out to 129
which I don't think can be simplified
I don't think there's any perfect
squares you can pull out of there is
there let's see 129 you could divide
that by three let's see
that's 43 but 43 is prime so it looks
like this is as far as you can go and
what we want to watch out for is that
you can't divide by zero so X couldn't
be 5 3 or negative 3 which this clearly
is not so that would be your final
answer so you've got two solutions here
great job if you want some more examples
follow me over to that video right there
where we talk about you know solving
more of these rational equations I'll
see you in that video